being a superhero
is a trial by fire who's gonna protect
the world if not people like you
I'm Jennifer Walters I'm a lawyer I have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
Division and I want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this but you still gotta
deal with it your Transformations are
triggered by anger and fear those are
like the Baseline of any woman just
existing oh how it feels like if I don't
transform I'm gonna die
yes yes yes no
no I just want to be a normal Anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where She Hulk is
Jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an Avenger oh I'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
the best that I've had in a while oh
should we split some fries let's get
those to go
foreign
[Music]